my name is true co-op I'm president of
our studio and I do this probably once a
year at use hour just to give people a
chance to give you people an update on
what we've been up to and then frankly
hopefully get some questions and have
some some dialogue there's a lot to
cover so I'm going to try and run
through things pretty quickly this
particular conference was interesting
because I got end up with a whole bunch
of conversations that highlighted that
maybe we need to spend a little more
time talking about who we are and what
we do which is not something that I was
planning on but anyway so this is our
mission it's it's pretty straightforward
it's it's aspirational obviously and and
as you can see by the name of the
company we're very much dedicated to our
we think that our is a fantastic
ecosystem and we want to make sure that
that continues to be a free and
open-source solution that's available to
people regardless of their economic
means and so when you look at how we
think about the world we we believe that
all the work that you do should be
reproducible and that invariably ends up
meaning that we believe that it should
be in code and so sorry okay it's not me
right all right who I'm like I can't do
anything else all right so so we believe
in API is designing good API is trying
to figure out what are the ways that
make it really easy for the data
scientists to get their work done
excellent I know that's not for me
either
I know I got it I got it all right so
70% of the engineering that we do goes
into open source software and I'll walk
you guys through some of the things that
we've done and then and our plan for
actually JJ and I met about four and a
half years ago and our plan from day one
was to say okay in order for this to
really work we need to have a structure
a company that is able to generate
enough revenue so that we can hire the
top minds so that they can you know top
engineers that can actually work on
solving these problems right and so the
company itself structurally is designed
to make that happen and and so what we
decided to do is we built these
commercial products we take our server
products and we add features and
capabilities around them that really are
about Enterprise fit so like larger
organizations that
already spending a lot of money on i.t
can go and say okay great if I'm
counting on are and I'm counting on
shiny arm counting on our studio I have
a way to be able to sort of call
somebody but more importantly maybe is
make sure that everything plugs into
what I would expect it to plug into
within my existing infrastructure so if
we put a lot of features around security
authentication monitoring tuning scaling
metrics high availability low balancing
etc these kinds of things so those of
you in the audience who are our
customers thank you very much the rest
of the slides and a lot of other sides
I'm going to show you here are only
possible because you guys are buying our
commercial products so let me run you
through first thing I wanted to
highlight is we in the last year have
actually been able to hire a bunch of
talent that is 8 that that can be
dedicated to improving our right and
whether it's in the tidy verse side of
the world will talk about tidy verse
wait did you guys okay I think you've
lost my audio right test yes okay good
I swear I have nothing to do with this
and or engineers on the shiny team or
frankly you guys are those of you who
are here yesterday could hear me talk
you know making sure that we're
investing more in education and outreach
within the community so how many people
here know about the tidy verse okay so
good I'm not going to explain it so
so I'm gonna highlight a few things here
so how many people are on the IDE 1.0 or
later okay those of you who are not on
there I would recommend that you take a
look at it there's all kinds of features
around notebooks data import there's a
new profiling tool in there how many
people know about the profiler being
there okay that's something for you to
discover so if you have slow code and
you want to try and figure out why it's
slow we try to make life easier for you
in that sense the other thing that we
did we announced this last year but I'm
guessing you know to this and this trip
I found out that not all the people know
about this is you know there's this
thing called spark the distributed
computing engine you know lots of hype
and we were hearing from people like oh
you know it doesn't work so well with
our we we have to use Python so what we
ended up doing is investing in both on
creating a package called sparkly R and
in improving the IDE so that the
integration is better obviously a ton of
time and testing and finding all the
edge cases and the things that don't
work inspire them things that don't work
properly and sparkly R etc so the idea
now is if you guys are interested I'll
have some links of them at the end you
can you can go in and you can get
yourself comfortable with with are
connecting to spark and leveraging the
power of spark without having to give up
on R and then here are the packages
packages I listed here are all packages
that were updated or created in the last
year the ones that are highlighted the
book blog down is in this color because
it's not on cranny yet all right so on
the shiny side we got 21.0 I should
mention we were on point one point on
the IDE we're on 1.0 and shiny
obviously upgrades to shiny server
itself there's a couple new packages
that we're working on they're not on
cran yet one is shiny tests and so one
of the big things is people create shiny
applications and then the organization
says hey you broke it when you did X Y Z
and so we recognized that because the
background of our community is is data
scientists right they're not software
engineers by training and the tooling is
not that great we're trying to create
tooling that makes life make life easier
for folks and my colleague Barbara
talked about pool so I won't cover that
too much
our markdown there's a new format called
book down how many people have heard of
book down
okay so book down is a format that may
it easy for you to write books in it and
we'll show you the website that you guys
can go to and take a look at it and you
can play with it and how many people are
familiar with parametrized reports okay
okay that's what I expected
so parametrized reports are you know you
guys are familiar with our markdown Docs
you can write our markdown Docs you can
actually pass in parameters if you if
you if you write your markdown doc in a
certain way you can have something in
the yamo file that specifies what the
parameters are and then you could render
the doc and by passing it in the
arguments and use those arguments within
the report that allows you to sort of
essentially personalize a report if you
want to or reuse a core logic for you
know something like okay I may run the
same report but for this different date
range or run the same report but for
North America versus South America
whatever right so all right we published
a new book our for data science and when
I say we I don't mean me I mean Garrett
and Hadley and and you can if you die
are you guys familiar with it yes kind
of sort of all right so there's a you
can read it online for free you can
obviously buy it too we also have a book
on book down if you go to book down or
Google actually see that not only do
there's every book on book down but
there are you know our for data science
book is also on there as well as other
people who publish books in there we
continue to have webinars we have cheat
sheets I think I know that people are
seeing the cheat sheets and we had our
first art studio conference in January
of this year the next one is going to be
at the end of January early February we
were we we had a group wonderful time
about 400 people managed to show up and
so if you guys are available at the end
of January early February you're
obviously more than welcome to come
along alright so how we think about data
science you guys may have seen this
before
oops all right it's good you know you
import data you tidy data you transform
the data you visualize the data you
model the data and you keep going and
then eventually the key thing behind
doing all data analysis is to
communicate right and so
all right so we decided to build a
product based on feedback that we got
from customers and just so be clear this
product is a professional product and
right now it's only available on premise
but ultimately in time we imagine that
we will have an on you know a
cloud-based solution that everybody in
the community can sort of leverage if
they want to right but and what this
product is aimed at is making it really
easy to go from from an analysis to
being able to sort of share that with
the rest of world so it's a push button
deploy of all the artifacts that user to
create out of our it's an on-premise
solution because most of our company and
customers will not run that in their
stuff outside the firewalls and so again
if you want to think about it you've got
you know you guys are the creators of
analyses you you may create note you may
notebooks you have static Docs you have
presentations you may have parametrized
our markdown Doc's as I said earlier you
can have shiny applications and
ultimately your goal is to communicate
this to somebody right somebody in the
organization needs to be able to to see
this and so we're trying to also build
in things like you know scheduling so if
you wanted to report to to run every
Monday and email people out or whatever
you can sort of do things like that
without having to sort of write your own
cron tabs or maybe you know have a
separate system call into now if you
want to you can absolutely do the same
thing all of the foundation of
everything that you see here is all open
source right people can recreate this
themselves at any point in time and I
expect that they will in terms of so
again creators there's artifacts there's
consumers and you guys are all familiar
with the work of the Creator right so
you ty you're tidying the whole tidy
transform visualized model but you also
care about reproducibility you care
about collaboration you care about
publishing you care about protecting
right so who can see this content when
can they see it and so on so forth right
and then on the consumer side they want
to be able to get a hold of the data
they want be able to explore the data
they may want to personalize and say I'm
only interested in reports about North
America or I'm only interested in
individual like southern Italy right or
or they may want my say if I saw I know
I saw you know Joe showed me a report or
a dashboard I want to see what that
looks like today can I go back and rerun
that myself right so the idea is if
you've already built this logic in our
we're going to try and make it more and
more accessible to the business user all
right so that's what Connect does
and the you know we're a lot of a lot of
our work ends up being providing
features that answer questions for the
IT organization on why are right the
data scientists are bought in they use
it they're building really great things
and then they run into these obstacles
within the IT organization so you know
we spend a lot of time trying to say
okay you know what here's how you tune
this here's how you monitor this here's
how you scale it you know we you know
like for connect for example I just
spent a pile of cash on an external
vendor firm to a security vendor firm to
come in and validate make sure that hey
you know what you know here are the
issues that we found that that is an
independent person take a look at that
and so we have a higher bar to cross
over because you know in in for IT
they're very familiar with a Python
solution stack and in many ways they ask
the data scientists on the our side to
hold themselves to a higher standard
than what you know what even you know
the rest of the organization is helping
but our job is to hopefully make it
easier and easier for that sale to
happen so deployment is a push-button
deployment we identify dependencies you
know we you know we use packrat
underneath the hood we match up our
versions to the best of our abilities
and and so the idea is get get more of
these artifacts that be published
quickly the reports all the reporting is
based on our markdown so it's completely
reproducible you can schedule it you can
email it you know ultimately in time you
can imagine that you can also have that
and like drop into a location on today's
cooktop into confluence and or
potentially like to send a slack message
or whatever right and and you can
customize you can give the end user the
opportunity to sort of customize the
report that they see based on the
parameters that they're interested in
and obviously can do everything around
hosting shiny applications
so generally architectural II this is
what it looks like you know you've got
the data is data scientist publishing on
one side you've got the end user sort of
interacting with others a web browser
they don't know that they're talking to
anything that is are related and all
right so useful websites shiny or pseudo
calm and guessing everybody here knows
about it our markdown at our studio calm
everybody yes
No
kind of all right you guys are falling
asleep on me DB our studio comm is a new
website it's talking about like it's
we're trying to capture all the things
that are related to sort of connecting
from our to the database spark that our
studio comm is the same kind of thing
but for spark book down we've talked
about a little bit and if you wanted to
play with connect we you can without
downloading it there's an eval that you
can download and run it but if you
wanted to just play with it and see what
the end user experience is like you
won't see all the features because it's
a common shared infrastructure but it
will give you a feel for like what you
can publish how you can schedule etc so
you can go to beta at art studio tacked
and just log in with your Google off
alright
so with that how many minutes we'll have
two and a half minutes questions
concerns nothing I can't actually see if
there are any hands out all right that's
it that's all I had
thanks
you